y yo el momento de hablar de revista de
prensa con rosa pérez en más de un rosa
feliz miércoles ya estamos a mitad de
semana y comenzamos entonces con el
diario punto es de españa porque una ong
marroquí y rosa denuncia la muerte de un
yemení en su intento de llegar a melilla
y señala a la guardia civil de
responsable que hay sobre esto buenos
días raúl exactamente esta es una
investigación publicada en el diario
punto es que hacer referencia a los
hechos ocurridos la noche del 20 de
noviembre lo que sucedió esta noche tal
y como relata este texto es que los dos
jóvenes yemeníes que huían de la guerra
de su país la mutación karim ibrahim
mohamed intentaron cruzar la frontera
entre marruecos y españa eso
concretamente en la zona de melilla que
recordemos melilla es un enclave español
en el norte de áfrica limítrofe
precisamente con marruecos bien estos
dos jóvenes intentaban cruzar a nado
pues las a las costas españolas de
melilla y lo que sucedió es que ya en
aguas españolas según cuenta el
superviviente de los hechos ibrahim
mohamed la policía española la guardia
civil concretamente los interceptó los
subió a su bote los apalizó y los
devolvió a aguas marroquíes y ahí les
quito el salvavidas y les volvió a
lanzar al mar bien mutasam karim de 26
años se ahogó en el mar según el testigo
de su amigo porque ibrahimovic consiguió
regresar a las costas marroquíes y en
base a su relato se ha podido llevar a
cabo esta investigación en cuenta que su
amigo aturdido e inconsciente fue
incapaz de regresar a nado a la costa y
que él mismo también en estado de shock
y pues tras las consecuencias de la
paliza y por una fuerte oleaje no pudo
arrastrarlo tampoco hasta las costas de
nuevo y bien la cuestión es que esta
investigación la ha realizado nuestra
también compañera sofía catalá vidal y
ella nos amplía esta información
veamos
la asociación marroquí de derechos
humanos denuncia la muerte y la
desaparición del cuerpo del solicitante
de asilo yemení mutasem karim a la noche
del 20 de noviembre mientras intentaba
llegar a nado desde la ciudad marroquí
de nador hasta la ciudad española de
melilla y señalan a la guardia civil
como responsable la denuncia se basa en
el testimonio de ibrahim mohamed también
solicitante de asilo y yemení quien
acompañaba a mutasem en la travesía
según explica el joven a una patrulla de
agentes de la guardia civil española les
sorprendió cuando ya estaban a punto de
llegar al puerto de melilla según
explica les golpearon dice literalmente
como si estuvieran en un ring de boxeo y
después les volvieron a arrojar al mar
para que volvieran nadando a marruecos
según explica el joven dice que su amigo
acabó muriendo ahogado ante sus ojos el
consiguió llegar a puerto otra vez al
puerto de nador a donde le recogió un
policía marroquí le llevaron a comisaría
y ya dice que le trataron bien le
tomaron declaración también tiene un
parte médico que evidencia el cuadro de
una paliza tenía traumatismos por todo
el cuerpo hematomas heridas
superficiales y también un shock
emocional según este parte el ministerio
del interior de españa niega la
información que denuncia la asociación
marroquí de derechos humanos y por parte
de la guardia civil de melilla dicen no
tener ningún tipo de información el
cuerpo de mutación no ha aparecido hasta
la fecha y la asociación marroquí de
derechos humanos pide que se busque el
cuerpo y también ibrahim mohamed y a los
familiares del fallecido piden que se
abra una investigación para esclarecer
los hechos y que se juzgue a los
responsables
bien raúl para concluir ya con este tema
recordamos que ibrahim mohamed en estas
declaraciones en este mismo artículo
redactado por sofía declara que si no
fuera por la guerra que hay en su país
no seguiría con este camino que está
completamente destrozado pero que aún
así quiere que se haga justicia
para su amigo y para todas las otras
personas que fallecen en las fronteras
europeas y españolas en este caso en
particular y es que según la asociación
caminando fronteras que monitorea lo que
sucede en la frontera el sur de españa
más de 2.000 personas han perdido la
vida en esta frontera en lo que va de
2021 y también apuntar que
organizaciones internacionales como
amnistía internacional piden a españa
entre otros países europeos que dejen de
exportar armamento a arabia saudí y
emiratos árabes países que participan en
esta guerra de yemen rosa gracias a por
toda esta información una denuncia
realmente triste muchísimas gracias
entonces rosa por todo a esta revista de
prensa del día de hoy nos vemos mañana
con más ahora vamos a saludar a nuestra
primera invitada al día
[Música]